bonjour chrétiens et musulmans
unissez-vous c'est l'appel lancé par le
pape au cours de son voyage en turquie
aujourd'hui chrétiens et musulmans
unissez-vous a faim a dit jean paul 2 de
protéger et de promouvoir ensemble pour
tous les hommes comme nous y invite le
concile la justice sociale les valeurs
morales la paix et la liberté
nous reviendrons dans un instant sur le
voyage de sa sainteté jean paul ii en
turquie autre appel un appel à la
compréhension c'est celui qu'a lancé
jean françois poncet le ministre des
affaires étrangères français avant le
sommet de dublin qui s'ouvre cet après
midi valéry giscard d'estaing a quitté
paris il ya de cela quelques instants
destination dublin pour ce conseil
européen
l'un des plus importants est l'un des
plus difficiles sans aucun doute depuis
l'ouverture de la communauté économique
européenne
il faudra beaucoup de compréhension à
tous les partenaires pour se sortir de
certaines impasses sur lesquels jacques
hébert reviendra dans un instant
également et puis nous parlerons de
l'iran l'iran qui a rejeté d'ores et
déjà toute résolution du conseil de
sécurité des nations unies qui tendrait
à condamner l'action entreprise par les
iraniens
les iraniens qui se sont donnés un
nouveau ministre des affaires étrangères
il s'appelle monsieur götze ad et vous
téléspectateurs de tf1 vous le
connaissez il était aux côtés de michel
bader et de moi-même à
neauphle-le-château monsieur gods année
était à ce moment là l'interprète de
l'ayatollah il est
c'est l'un des proche de l'ayatollah y
c'est lui qui au cours de l'interview
que nous avions réalisé à
neauphle-le-château interprétait les
propos de l'ayatollah khomeini un fidèle
du chat sera notre invité tout à l'heure
dans cette émission de 13 heures un
fidèle du chat qui témoignent il a
rencontré le chat à new york il y a de
cela quelques jours
il témoignera dans cette édition de 13
heures comme il a témoigné pour
l'hebdomadaire vsd cette semaine voilà
les principaux sujets de cette édition
de 13 heures au cours de laquelle nous
parlerons également de la fondation de
la vocation mais tout de suite direction
dublin
le conseil européen s'ouvre tout à
l'heure jacques hébert est sur place
nous allons rejoint c'est dans ce triste
château grisâtre construit au xiiie
siècle en plein centre de dublin que
commencera tout à l'heure ce troisième
conseil européen de l'année
un conseil qui promet d'être l'un des
plus difficiles et l'un des plus tendus
de la brède histoire de la communauté
européenne
et c'est une fois de plus l'enfant
terrible de l'europe le royaume uni qui
créera le suspense en dehors des
problèmes agricoles ou en discutera
pêle-mêle de lait de beurre de sucre de
mouton ou de langoustines
le problème essentiel sera certainement
celui de la contribution britannique au
budget européen
de quoi s'agit-il la grande-bretagne
pays chaque année 20 % du budget total
de l'europe et en retour ne bénéficie
que d'un dixième de ce budget côté
britannique on parle d'injustice et on
demande une réduction substantielle de
cette contribution
une réduction de 6 milliards de francs
réponse des partenaires européens
si vous payez cher à la communauté c'est
parce que vous apportez pour plus de 40%
à l'extérieur de l'europe
n'oubliez pas qu'il y a des règles
communautaires que vous avez signé lors
de votre adhésion en 73 toutefois nous
sommes prêts à faire un geste mais pas
plus que 3 milliards de réduction
d'autant plus que ce sera à nous les
huit autres partenaires de combler le
manque à gagner du budget européen
en tout cas d' exceptionnelle mesures de
sécurité ont été prises ici à dublin
dublin où vient d'être condamné à
perpétuité
un terroristes de l'ira pour le meurtre
de lord mountbatten conali et
inédits sont d'accord carter a été bien
dans sa conférence de presse en parlant
de la situation des états unis face à la
crise iranienne calme et détermination
ce sont les deux mots employés du reste
par la presse américaine pour qualifier
les propos tenus par le président qui
apparemment donc fait l'unanimité
derrière les positions affirmées
positions en particulier tels que celle
ci nous ne céderons pas nous les états
unis au santa à washington dominique
bromberger serveurs marqués par la
fatigue due à 25 jours de crise mais
calme et sûr de lui même que les
américains ont dû apparaître dernière à
la télé mais l'exécutif a encore franchi
un degré dans l'escaladé verbale qui
l'oppose à l'ayatollah khomeyni en
évoquant l'irresponsabilité des
dirigeants iraniens en affirmant que
ceux qui seront tenus lamentable et très
graves conséquences quand même fait les
autres artistes va libérer et andy
d'anglesey au mérite et la honte de
laisser de plumes se venger et carter a
très clairement fait savoir qu'il
entendait continuer à explorer toutes
les polices des diplômes est il de ce
avant de recourir à la force il a refusé
de signer pour l'instant à cet éventuel
recours
il ne faisait guère de doute à travers
ces propos je ferai tout mon possible
pour les le président américain n'a
d'ailleurs pas écarté l'hypothèse d'une
enquête internationale sur les
actualités du ca en hausse en au
bataclan qui n'existait pas à ces
connexions de plus sages chargé de ce
genre d'activités les réactions à cette
conférence de presse ont été annoncés
ligne dans tous les candidats lillers
soient démocrates ou républicains l'ont
approuvé pour le thème du me sens si
nous n'avons qu'un seul président
l'énergie pendant ce temps un terran on
prépare la grande fête chiite de demain
l'achoura est aujourd'hui manifestation
monstre dans les rues de téhéran
manifestation qui a abouti à son terme à
la condamnation de toute résolution
possible condamnant l'iran
solution du conseil de sécurité de
l'organisation des nations unies raymond
girard à téhéran la nomination au poste
de ministre des affaires étrangères en
remplacement de sa nissan semble inviter
du recrutement de la politique étrangère
iranienne
messieurs danny stam a donc été désavoué
par les ailes de la commune ou bien que
garde le portefeuille de l'économie et
des clients le fait qu'il ait reçu le
parlementaire américaine ron hainsey il
est annoncé son intention de se rendre
là julie bref il est montré une certaine
souplesse et une tendance à la
négociation
la guerre était privé au syndic
entraîneur du mans on accomplit sa place
dans une ligue
l'ayatollah comédie l'eifel enduiseur
l'histogramme est une confiance totale
avec le tchad est dans lé bruit quand ça
dure à l'égard des sept villes sont bien
connus on ne se faisait aucune
concession est envisageable
ou bien les états unis rendent de chat
ou bien les otages basse conduisent man
ray jugement devant un tribunal
islamique dans les sanctions pourraient
aller jusqu'à la peine de mort selon les
propres termes du spectacle et mme
girard est du cas monsieur gazza des a
d'ores et déjà fait savoir qu'ils
n'étaient pas dans son intention de se
rendre au conseil de sécurité de
l'organisation des nations unies dans
toute résolution vient d'être condamné
par les iraniens manifestants à terre ce
gotha des nous ne connaissions bien il
était à paris pendant de longues années
un autre homme proche du chat lui est à
paris en ce moment il a rencontré le
chat il ya de cela quelques jours dans
l'hôpital de new york un hôpital que le
shah d'iran peut quitter quand ils le
souhaitent c'est ce qu'ont dit les
médecins ce matin après les derniers
examens
alors on se demande justement si le chat
va quitter new york bientôt cette
question je les poser dans des
circonstances un peu exceptionnel à cet
homme l'un des fidèles du chat encore
aujourd'hui un homme qui risque sa vie
et c'est pour cela que les conditions de
l'interview sont un peu exceptionnel je
n'ai reçu il
cela quelques instants dans mon bureau
ici à la télévision il ne souhaitait pas
être reconnus parce qu'ils pourraient
attenté à ses jours comme il ne
souhaitait pas que son nom soit écrit
dans vsd puisque cette semaine il
témoigne aussi pour cet hebdomadaire
dans une longue interview accordée à nos
confrères de vsd que vous pourrez
trouver dès aujourd'hui alors tout de
suite quelques réponses de ce personnage
proche du chat est d'abord une réponse à
la question le chat va-t-il quitter new
york bien ce qu'il quittera new york le
3 ou 4 décembre prochain pour le mexique
d'ailleurs quand il est arrivé à new
york le 22 octobre dernier il avait été
convenu que ce serait un traitement de
six à sept semaines et il est
parfaitement dans les délais alors vous
l'avez rencontrée dans quel état moral
et il en est amoral cyclothymique c'est
un homme qui a des hauts et des bas un
peu comme sa santé maintenant et des
moments de grande euphorie et des
moments de grande dépression
c'est selon les nouvelles qu'il reçoit
mais selon aussi les visiteurs qu'il
reçoit ce week end il était dépressif
mais la semaine dernière selon des amis
à moi il était en bonne forme parce
qu'ils avaient vu des gens très
importants aussi bien du bloc
occidentale qu'orientale qui viennent le
questionner et les poser des questions
pour savoir qu'est ce qu'il pense et que
va devenir ces pays en tout cas le ça
est encore à new york il quittera sans
aucun doute new york pour mexico à la
date que vient de vous donner mon
interlocuteur c'est à dire dans les
prochains jours et de l'a2 mexico y
at-il dans les intentions du chat la
possibilité d'un retour en iran il ne
pense pas à ça et il ne veut pas y
penser du moins dans son temps dans son
intime conviction il pense d'abord ce
que va devenir l'iran il a des rapports
et que certains chefs d'états non
seulement musulmans mais des gens de la
région et tout le monde est effaré par
ce vent de folie qui souffle
actuellement
tu retires ans la mecque et rawalpindi
qui peut demain éclaté à jakarta en
indonésie qui est musulman qui peut
balayer le roi hassan ou le président
sadate en passant par toute l'afrique du
nord et le golf
alors actuellement c'est la région
l'iran n'est qu'un petit point là dedans
et je pense que le chat pense d'abord la
stabilité de la région et à des contacts
avec aussi bien des pays arabes que les
pays voisins arabes pour voir comment
maintenir cette région dans une pseudo
stabilité très fragile il ne parle pas
de reconquête
non il ne parle pas de reconquête mais à
une question que je lui avais posé il ya
un mois et demi cela au mexique lui
demandant s'il avait envie de revenir un
jour dans son pays il m'a dit ce pays là
je ne le connais pas donc je n'ai pas
envie de le reconnaître si je peux
reprendre mon travail là où je les
interrompue il y a un an
contraint et forcé et refaire le même
travail avec les mêmes collaborateurs
peut-être de manière différente alors
peut-être voulait-il dire par là pas de
répression pas de sa vague pas tout ça
je suis partant mais si c'est pour
devenir un roi qui inaugure les
chrysanthèmes
non je ne retrouverai jamais mon pays
voilà pour cette interview de ce
personnage ou elie très proche encore de
ce chat d'iran actuellement en aux états
unis toujours en surveillance médicale
mais qui peut désormais quitter
l'hôpital quand il le souhaite
les autres titres de l'actualité jean
pierre pernaut oui bien d'abord un
commentaire de françois ceyrac président
du cnpf qui se trouvent aux états unis à
propos de cette crise iranienne c'est la
plus grave crise depuis 1945 at il dit
en raison de ses prolongements possibles
au niveau mondial le voyage du pape en
turquie après un accueil plutôt froid
hier dans ce pays à 99 % musulman
les entretiens politiques de jean paul
ii à ankara ont été plus importants que
prévu à istanbul où le souverain pontife
est arrivé tout à l'heure rejoignant
tout de suite notre envoyé spécial
bernard chevalier 24 heures après son
arrivée en turquie jean paul ii en est
toujours à la phase diplomatique et
touristique de son voyage ce matin avant
de prendre l'avion pour istanbul
il a devant la toute petite communauté
catholique d'ankara souhaité que les
liens spirituels qui unissent l'islam au
christianisme
développe et il a même demandé qu'une
collaboration s'instaure en vue des
progrès de l'homme et de la paix ces
propos seront de nature à rassurer les
milieux les plus intégristes musulmans
qui avait présenté le voyage du pape
comme une relance d'une croisade
orthodoxes catholiques contre l'islam
accueil discret tout à l'heure à
l'aéroport d'istanbul
douze personnalités religieuses
catholiques orthodoxes mieux juive et
anglicane était venu saluer jean paul ii
parmi elles bien sûr dimitrios premier
le patriarche que jean paul ii
rencontrera tout à l'heure et demain
c'est le moment important de ce voyage
pour l'instant le pape est toujours
entre les mains des autorités turques
qui lui font visiter sanofi l'antique
basilique byzantine devenu mosquée puis
musée et puis aussi top capi ce musée si
riche des trésors des sultans la presse
turque ce matin se montrent moins
agressive à l'égard de jean paul ii tous
les titres produisent une flat photos
représentant paul jean paul ii
embrassant la terre la campagne de
presse qui s'était développé ces jours
derniers contre lui aura en tout cas
permis à une population qui jusqu'à leur
était indifférente ou ignorante de
savoir qu'un homme de dieu était venu
chez elle aujourd'hui istanbul tf1
bernard chevallier toujours à l'étranger
il faut savoir que des rebelles
continuerait à résister dans les
sous-sols de la grande mosquée de la
mecque
et puis qu au salvador l'ambassadeur
d'afrique du sud a été enlevé hier soir
sans doute par un commando d'extrême
gauche
dans l'actualité sociale en france
beaucoup de perturbations un peu partout
aujourd'hui à la sncf d'abord avec
toujours des grèves sur le réseau
sud-est dans les transports parisiens
arrêt total du métro ce matin pendant
une heure une heure de grève également à
l' agence france-presse
à l'appel de la cgt et de la cfdt ces
deux syndicats ont également lancé un
mot d'ordre d'arrêt de travail de 24
heures dans les ptt
enfin vous le savez les aiguilleurs du
ciel continuent leur mouvement et dans
certaines régions comme celle de lyon il
n'y aura aucun décollage aujourd'hui en
revanche fin du conflit à nice matin
la parution du journal a été assuré
normalement pour la première fois ce
matin depuis 15 ans à propos de presse
vous savez que la nouvelle formule du
quotidien de paris qui paraît depuis ce
matin a publié un sondage consacré à
l'intervention de monsieur giscard
d'estaing mardi dernier nous en parlions
hier soir est bien autre sondage sur le
même thème dans le journal l'aurore près
de 80 % des téléspectateurs qui ont
accepté de répondre se disent convaincus
par les explications du président pour
65% d'entre eux monsieur giscard
d'estaing est proche de leurs
préoccupations publication ce matin du
rapport annuel du conseil d'information
sur l'énergie électro-nucléaire c'est
une brochure de 170 pages qui fait le
bilan des travaux de cet organisme on
sait que les organisations qui
critiquent le programme électronucléaire
français reprochent au gouvernement de
ne pas suffisamment informé les gens
précisément ce matin le conseil
entendait les doléances de ces
organisations qui souhaitent élargir le
débat sur le thème de l'électronucléaire
françois close et a demandé à simone
veil présidente du conseil d'information
de faire le bilan de son action depuis
un an il y avait des raisons sérieuses à
ne pas publier les plans orsec
de radiation les rapports sur l'état de
la radioactivité dans l'environnement et
cetera est-ce que c'est pas de mauvaises
habitudes absurde pour les plans
d'intervention vous avez évoqué on
appelle quelques fois le plan orsec vous
dire que ça aussi ça a été fait est
qu'on l'obligé obligé l'administration à
ce qu'ils soient mieux préparés mieux
élaborés c'est donc une bonne chose et
le gouvernement a pris l'engagement et a
déjà commencé à les diffuser et
diffusera ceux qui n'ont pas encore
débuté avant le 1er avril 1980 pendant
un an
l'administration le ministère les df ont
menti par omission ne disant pas aux
français ce qu'ils avaient sur des
ennuis qu'ils avaient ans dans le
domaine de la métallurgie nucléaire ce
qu'on a appelé les fissures
le conseil a condamné cela est ce que
maintenant vous avez l'assurance que de
telles choses ne se reproduiront alors
ce qui est difficile et ce que nous
allons essayer d'ailleurs de voir parce
que nous n'avons pas terminé notre
informe notre propre information au
conseil sur ce point c'est de voir à
quel moment dans une connaissance de
petits incidents de routine
il faut informer parce qu'on peut penser
que ce n'est plus de la routine et que
ça devient réellement quelque chose qui
va être porté haut et c'est très très
difficile c'est ce que nous sommes c'est
ce qu'on nous a expliqué et que nous
avons très bien perçue avec des exemples
précis mais il est certain qu'il ya tout
de même sans doute un moment où chacun
se pose la question au niveau de ceux
qui sont informés que dire d'un with non
plus donc dans le quotidien
c'est précisément est ce que le
manquement qui a été commis n'a pas
consisté à ne pas demander à votre
conseil s'il fallait tout non publiés
récemment mais je prends c'était au
conseil a déroulé les je crois qu'en
réalité c'est toujours la même question
c'est à quel moment et il lui nous
saisir
c'est très difficile je crois ce qui est
ce que nous avons
dix déjà au président d'edf c'est qu'il
faut être plus vigilant et certainement
il faut faire en amont et donc peut-être
ensemble nous allons rechercher quelle
est le signe l'alertent en quelque sorte
qui peut donner à penser qu' il devrait
y avoir de l'information
toujours en france un commentaire
politique intéressant commentaire de
michel rocard à france inter il est
maintenant plus loyale at-il dit plus
loyal d'expliquer clairement que les
projets socialistes et communistes ne
sont pas de même nature rapidement
encore les calculatrices électroniques
seront autorisées dès la prochaine
session du baccalauréat vignette
il vous reste jusqu'à samedi à minuit
pour l'acheter enfin les sens elle
augmentera sans doute dès la fin de
cette semaine entre 5 et 10 centimes par
litre à propos de carburant regarder ce
qui n'est pour l'instant qu'une maquette
qu'un projet la future voiture anti
gaspi de renault dimension d'une r18
elle s'appellera eve et consommera 25 %
de carburant en moins
premier essai vers la fin 1980 le
pétrole toujours ce sera l'un des thèmes
du magazine économique de tf1 l'enjeu ce
soir à 21h30 avec un reportage notamment
sur le détroit d'ormuz tout près de
l'iran par où passent les deux tiers du
pétrole de l'opep est un des trois dont
on parle beaucoup en ce moment la météo
maintenant le temps sera souvent
ensoleillé aujourd'hui mais dans le sud
ouest les brouillards vont persister
demain le temps va se gâter près de la
manche avec beaucoup de nuages ailleurs
toujours du soleil quand le brouillard
aura disparu une météo qui inquiète les
habitants de madrid une grisaille
épaisse recouvre toute la ville cette
pollution atmosphérique affecte déjà les
personnes âgées et les autorités
espagnoles envisage de prendre des
mesures d'urgences réduction du
chauffage et de la circulation notamment
hier soir en tout cas c'était du
brouillard qui recouvrait le stade
geoffroy-guichard à saint-etienne sur
tf1 on a quand même pu apercevoir le
premier but de platini sur penalty en
deuxième mi-temps on y voyait beaucoup
mieux et saint-etienne a marqué 3 au
produit par lario ce le voilà par le
virus contre son camp après une tête de
platini vous allez le voir
et puis le jeune stéphanois laurent
roussey entraient sur le terrain et la
nouvelle mascotte de saint-etienne
marque est un quatrième
laurent roux s'est montré encore pour
deux matches oui c'est encore un but
décidément ça vient d'habitude on
habitue qui j'espère superbe a pas main
lady un peu à tout le monde
je pense que
quand même remercier les seize parce que
si on est carrément une collectivité il
ya 11 joueurs et si j'arrive à marquer
des buts c'est grâce aux deux teasers
trouvèrent c'est finalement dangereux
tout cela parce que finalement vous avez
trop toujours en place
non je pense pas disons en toute façon
pour moi ce n'est pas un problème
actuellement je pense ne pas vouloir
tenir 90 minutes surtout au rythme de la
coupe d'europe ils ont que rentrée 25
minutes je peux me livrer avant et une
le maximum comment vous sentez vous
après quatorze mois donné disons qu'on
retrouve petit à petit il
le grand succès devant moi enfin il
faudra quand même encore deux ou trois
mois pour arriver à la plénitude de mes
moyens
le but de ce soir blue & me l'expliquer
ça s'est passé très vite avec michel
l'heure est venue pour le coach les bus
sur le quesnoy gpra mai
alors simple hossein blanchet me disais
il ya de cela quelques jours lorsque je
lui parlais de la fondation de la
vocation 20e édition qui aura lieu au
niveau de la cérémonie de remise des
bourses le 5 décembre c'est à dire
mercredi prochain prenez mes lauréats je
préfère que ce soit eux qui souhaitent à
l'honneur de sorte qu'aujourd'hui et
bien trois lauréats de la vocation 20e
anniversaire cette année sont avec nous
aujourd'hui
alors il y a d'abord l'un des plus
anciens michel siffre qui a réussi sa
carrière peut être un peu grâce à la
vocation ou complètement grâce à la
location les deux les deux si je n'avais
pas eu la vocation il n'y aurait pas eu
l'afp la suite ça m'a donné le courage
de me battre et ça ça a été le plus
important ensuite ça m'a obligé à être
un leader et m'obligeant à être un
leader dont j'ai entraîné derrière moi
un paquet d'hommes des savons des
chercheurs et c'est toute une dynamique
comme la vocation vous le savez on l'a
où on l'a peint et puis c'est tout alors
vous aviez votre bourse en 1960
vous pensiez à quoi ce moment là
exactement elle devait servir à quoi à
cette bourse
la recherche l'action est avec pour
thème central la spéléologie bien sûr
les grottes savez que c'est ma passion
les grottes la géologie tout ce qui
touche le monde souterrain bon je crois
que c'est pas mal après vingt ans j'ai
vraiment vécu ce que j'ai voulu vivre et
ça c'est le plus important le reste
l'argent ça n'a pas d'importance si vous
avez encore la vocation aujourd'hui
ah oui oui pareil qu'avant et j'ai eu
des coups durs j'ai gagné je suis
redescendu j'ai gagné puis maintenant
j'ai pareil à nouveau savez avec
l'amérique centrale maintenant j'ai une
vocation qui redevenu aussi forte
peut-être plus forte que ce qu'elle
était il ya encore quelques années
pourquoi mairie centrale vous y
retrouver des choses extraordinaires
mais vous savez que en gros ce que nous
venons de découvrir c'est un nouvel art
je viens de découvrir des grottes avec
une centaine de sculptures souterraine
des des stalagmites sculpté quelque
chose dont on avait dans les
archéologues ne soupçonnait même pas
l'existence rien et est bon on a fait
quoi avec mon camarade gérard cap
en l'espace de quoi de quelques
campagnes d'exploration vous rendez
compte des sculptures d'un style nouveau
et ça c'est quelque chose de nouveau à
l'échelle mondiale et c'est j'ai attendu
je vais vous dire quelque chose une
confidence je n'ai jamais dit j'ai
attendu
ça fait presque un an que j'ai fait ces
découvertes j'ai entendu que ce soit
pour le 20e anniversaire de vocations
que j'annonce et découvertes
cette année nous avons découvert des
monolithes extraordinaire des
stalagmites de deux mètres cinquante de
haut sculptées jamais même dans le monde
préhistorique français on en avait
découvert n'avait pas de photo avec vous
là non pas avec moi mais je vais avoir
bientôt peut-être ce soir nous les
présenter je les présenterai promis
alors ils viennent d'où d'après vous
alors là vous me posez la question clé
la question clé je crois avoir découvert
l'origine de l'art dans le monde mais
aux américains dans le monde américain
ce que nous trouvons je suis j'ai
découvert les choses au guatemala en
plein coeur de la civilisation maya vous
en avez entendu parler avec ses
pyramides magnifique et cette écriture
hiéroglyphique et dont on ne connaît pas
l'origine
or ce que j'ai découvert ce n'est pas
maria c'est plus primitifs d'autre part
dans la même région un peu plus haut
dans le nord au mexique on a découvert
les grandes têtes olmèques c'est quand
la tête géante poule gens qui ont visité
ces pays les connaissent et là non plus
ce que j'ai trouvé n'est pas comme ça
alors comme c'est très primitif très
fruste mais en même temps très beau je
crois qu'on est à la limite je pense je
les a prévu - deux mille ans avant 2000
3000 avant jésus-christ les prémices
l'origine de l'art de la civilisation
maya ou allemand c'est une révolution
et ça va faire du bruit vous allez voir
dès que les publications scientifiques
vont paraître simultanément en france et
aux états unis
ça va faire mal alors est ce que pour
nicolas baigner ça va faire mal aussi
avec cette bourde qui a sûrement vous
vous êtes lauréats de cette année
vous êtes habitué à être l'arrière vous
à une combien de bourse du 3 au 4 rue
les français non c'était surtout
américaines grande bretagne et c'était
toujours des bourse pour aller étudier
quelque part donc ce n'a jamais été des
bourses pour aller ce que c'est pour
aller faire ce que je veux faire
ok je voulais faire ce que je veux faire
c'est d'aller vivre avec les polynésie
et de les écouter d'écouter ce qu'ils
disent pourquoi ils le disent comment
ils le disent vous parlez combien de
langues
environ 6 7 langues vous avez 21 ans
j'ai 21 6 ou 7 langues appris sur le tas
ou apprise à l'école ce dépend y en a eu
trois qui ont été apprises plus ou moins
facilement avec parents et cetera
les autres ont été apprises soit l'école
soit dans le pays
je j'ai tendance à les absorber assez
facilement quand je suis dans le pays
lui même la plus originale la plus
originale sauvette les tongiens qui est
la langue que j'étudie maintenant et
c'est une langue qui est parlée dans
l'archipel des tonga qui dans le
pacifique du sud au sud de ça moi que
tout le monde la connaît et c'est par
l'envié ou par cinq cent vingt mille
habitants
et c'est la langue la plus ancienne de
la polynésie pour vous cette bourse de
la vocation c'est le rêve
c'est vrai on vous présente comme un
surdoué vous l'êtes non 6 à 9 mois jeudi
six années un nom c'est ce mot ne veut
rien dire
je crois que beaucoup la plupart des
gens ont beaucoup de deux blocs émotif
qui ne les empêche d'utiliser toutes
leurs facultés et c'est peut-être plus
nature de blocage c'est çà et là
dernière c'est marie laure menant alors
vous vous venez d'où des nautiques de la
martinique et vous intéresser à la
grammaire à g et oui le petit petit
depuis l'âge de 9 ans j'étais passionné
par la grammaire et j'ai eu la chance
d'avoir les professeurs extraordinaires
les sept tours de france et
je crois qu'ils ont beaucoup contribué à
cultiver cet enthousiasme pour tous qui
antiquités créer de la terre et même le
ciel français
oui peut-être discuter a gagné en grec
vous parler grec non non on est tous
d'accord entre l'initiation voilà on
s'est donné rendez vous en tout cas
cette bourse des vocations vous
permettra de réaliser votre rêve obtenir
une agrégation
mais oui parce que l'an dernier je les
présente et les ja et j'ai fait celui un
gros échec maintenant catastrophé par ce
que je dois dire que j'ai eu de gros
problèmes à travailler à l'élection
grand verre tout d'abord j'ai dû
travailler par correspondance fois voir
là le dogue la licence la maîtrise et je
me suis rendu compte que travail est en
correspondance aux bibliothèques sont
incultes et la martinique
je me suis beaucoup de mal de la mesure
où je perdais un tout ce que je
connaissais je vivais sur mes réserves
si bien que la navigation jeunes et un
niveau compétitif bien en tout cas bravo
à tous les trois très bientôt michel
siffre je vous garde et j'attends les
photos quant à nous nous allons donner
la parole aujourd'hui dans le cadre de
la présentation des élections
prud'homales à la cftc
tout le monde je crois commence à savoir
que cette institution prud'homale est
essentiel pour garantir les droits
individuels des salariés et pour la cftc
nous y attachons un intérêt tout
particulier dans la mesure où je crois
nous jouons un rôle complémentaire c'est
à dire que à travers nos efforts de
politique contractuelle pour couvrir
tous les salariés avec des conventions
nous établissant ses droits et les
prud'hommes vient en prolongement pour
garantir ses droits c'est dire l'intérêt
que nous y apportons cette élection at
elle pour vu un enjeu syndicale bien sûr
puisque les syndicats vont appuyer les
travailleurs quand titre ou devant les
prud'hommes
mais je crois qu'au delà de cet aspect
pratique c'est une occasion absolument
essentiel puisque pour la première fois
depuis 17 ans 13 à 14 millions de
salariés devront se
annoncée entre les différentes
organisations syndicales fr un choix
syndicale en quoi vous démarquez-vous
des autres grandes organisations
syndicales nous nous démarquons sur
plusieurs points je crois qu'il est
important que les travailleurs le mesure
car en effet pour la majorité des
téléspectateurs le syndicalisme c'est en
général c'est guillemer bergeron
également mais il y a pratiquement il
faut avoir le courage de le dire
les trois quarts des salariés qui ne
sont pas syndiqués et à notre avis c'est
la preuve que les travailleurs cherchent
autre chose et la cftc est convaincu de
pouvoir effectivement apporter autre
chose
par exemple en matière de refus de la
politisation
c'est une règle d'or pour nous que
l'indépendance syndicale et vous savez
notamment que c'est une des raisons
majeures de notre rupture il ya quelques
années avec la cfdt
lorsque après la cgt elle s'est engagée
dans cette voie qui à notre avis a fait
un mal considérable syndicalisme de ce
pays
nous sommes farouchement attachée à la
défense du droit de grève mais non moins
farouchement attaché à son abus car ça
déconsidère la grève et nous cherchons à
utiliser la grève vraiment comme ultime
recours des travailleurs est également
de donner à ceux qui n'ont pas toujours
les moyens de faire grève des
possibilités de recours à travers des
procédures de médiation que nous
essayons de généraliser mais en ce qui
concerne les réformes de structure
quelle est l'originalité de la cftc sur
un niveau très concret celui des
entreprises
elle entend que les salariés ne
subissent pas simplement de les
conséquences notamment en matière
d'emploi de décisions qui sont prises en
dehors d'eux elle veut que les
travailleurs soit associée directement à
l'élaboration de la politique des
entreprises je crois que c'est également
une originalité de la cftc est il
vraiment très important pour vous que
les salariés votent à ces élections du
12 décembre absolument fondamental et
notre grande rue consignes
c'est de dire aux salariés de prendre
leurs responsabilités ce jour là c'est
défendre leur liberté que d'utiliser ce
droit de vote
s'abstenir c'est démissionner c'est
renoncer le droit à critiquer donc que
tout le monde vote
et j'ajouterais si vous voulez que les
salariés de ce pays vote de pour un
syndicalisme actif mais constructif et
je crois que à travers cela si on
renforce la cftc on peut vraiment
changer le climat social de ce pays et
il en a bien besoin
et maintenant françois de lahti la
bourse car la bourse de paris il ya
également un petit changement de climat
mais dans le sens inverse à bhl cette
fois ci c'est le retour au calme après
l'affolement à auquel on a assisté un
petit peu hier en effet les cours de
l'or ont été stabilisées à l'annonce
d'une vente probable du ministère des
finances américain dans certaines d'une
certaine quantité d'or du coup les
valeurs qui avaient monté avant-hier et
baissé hier repartent de l'avant et en
tête on retrouve comme avant-hier un
contrat d'exploitation de l'afrique
occidentale
la copine du midi aux immobilière et
c'est un record de hausse pour l'année
et l'institut national de la statistique
ayant des et que les biens
intermédiaires tels que les six mois par
exemple se portait mieux on trouve peu
liette et lafarge qui sont en hausse
paul y est en particulier
alors ce que sont ses revenus consolidés
pour 1979 seront au moins le double je
suis l'année dernière et que le
dividende augmentera au ce record
également sur une valeur de boissons la
proche des fêtes de noël pernod ricard
pernod ricard qui d'une part annonce que
ses ventes en urss vont se développer
il n'est même pas impossible que pernod
ricard installe implante une usine en
urss et d'autre part on dit mais c'est
une rumeur non confirmée que pernod
ricard pourrait procéder à une
distribution d'actions gratuites ou la
hausse de 7,1 pour cent aujourd'hui la
science au perrier qui avaient beaucoup
baissé à la suite de l'interdiction de
la sorte front thèse à rattraper
maintenant que ce retard d'où la
remontée de jours à la construction
électrique qu'il y avait certaines
irrégularités
la liste amat pratique continue sa
remontée en sens inverse
l'acm au contraire est en baisse parmi
les principales baisses d'aujourd'hui
ainsi que le grand en revanche là
sf au milieu du tableau monte de 1 0% la
css annonce qu' elle va participer à des
commandes pour l'amélioration de la
défense nationale en grande-bretagne
cette nouvelle et bien interprété pour
le marché d'une manière générale les
valeurs informatiques des valeurs
d'électronique sont toujours parmi les
vedettes de la bourse de passe alors
allons y il ya eu immobilité en ce sens
que l'once d'or cote et 410 dollars 90
comme hier soir mais à paris on assiste
encore à une hausse car les cours que
vous voyez maintenant sont naturellement
comparés à ceux d'hier à midi et par
rapport à hier midi il ya eu un grand
changement puisque on a monté dans la
soif donc le lingot de la barre monte de
600 francs le kilo lui monte de 1280
francs le napoléon est a lui aussi un
cours record en montant de 540 les
valeurs indexé sur l'or sont
irrégulières à 1370 francs leucate et me
concentre baisse de 3 francs mais à 5699
francs le 7 % d'une sanction traduit est
en hausse de 34 francs les mines d'or
sont en hausse et les valeurs
américaines aussi ici labour j'avoue
qu'il mourut merci françois donati
rendez vous si vous le souhaitez deux
mâts nous parlerons beaucoup de sport à
l'institut national des sports en direct
et je vous donne rendez vous dans quatre
13h au revoir